eric let's start with you let's um talk
about a etf an exchange traded fund what
exactly is the advantage to these etfs
versus let's say uh the bitcoin trust uh
that greyscale has or some of the other
uh kind of fun structures that are in
the
market generally speaking an etf is
probably the superior wrapper for just
about everything
um obviously you can do a lot on your
own if you do anything on here you could
buy the s p 500 stocks on your own you
could buy gold and store it on your own
there's nothing wrong with that
uh but you know this is a world where
consumers like convenience so but you
can log on to any exchange buy the etf
uh it has a three four letter ticker
trades on the public exchanges it's been
sort of allowed or approved by the sec
so you have that kind of comfort
it has liquidity you can trade it
intraday
and and in this case there'll be options
on it that's very uh useful helpful so
etfs generally have just made it easy to
democratize investing
gbtc
uh has done all that the problem with
gbtc is
it's not really an etf you cannot uh
you cannot create and redeem shares on
demand which means arb is not possible
and when arb is not possible you have a
price deviating from the nav with etfs
you can create and uh destroy shares uh
whenever you want therefore if the price
gets away you can arb that and then the
price gets away you can arbitrage
constant r been going on keeping the
price close to the underlying uh price
of what is tracking which is what people
want i mean that that's at the end of
the day they get bitcoins volatile
uh they want something that tracks the
price that's it they just that's the
bottom line and gbtc does not do that
got it and james when you think about
let's take gbtc obviously it's traded at
a massive premium at times a massive
discount is that really the big thing
that people are going to drive interest
to the etfs is the fact that the other
publicly traded vehicles right now have
those discounts and premiums and so this
won't and that four will drive some of
the inflows
yeah i think that that's definitely part
of it um right now gbtc is trading at
like it's just about 18 discount to the
nav so basically what eric was talking
about in a typical etf you can exchange
shares for the underlying on a daily
basis so that means if they're the same
exact thing you can always make sure
that the price is worth exactly what it
holds with gbtc you can't do that so you
can right now the fund is closed you
can't even create shares and there is no
redeeming of shares so that whole
mechanism of being able to take the
delivery of the underlying uh just isn't
it isn't possible but again it's trading
at a discount to nav right now so uh so
if you wanted to buy gbtc and you were
expecting it to convert to an etf that
is a potential premium if you will in
the returns that you can generate but as
eric said over the short term gbt tends
to trade very closely to bitcoin price
like over a day um it's it's correlation
it's beta to the bitcoin market is
pretty close but over the long term it
just breaks down um because of those
reasons if you bought it at a huge
premium those times were trading at 120
above what it was worth so you were
buying 50 000 bitcoin when bitcoin was
actually trading at twenty thousand
dollars so um that that's the problem
and there are issues with it but there
are what we can get into the nuances of
it they're also going to be some issues
with the futures etfs as well so you
just kind of need to know the the issues
with both and understand the pros and
cons
i want to just add the number here if
you bought gbtc last year
on this date
you would be trailing the price of
bitcoin by 160 percentage points
now there's times where you bought gbtc
and it actually outperformed bitcoin the
the problem is you don't know it's it's
got a third element and people generally
don't like the third element that's why
close end funds uh have really not you
know that's an area of the market that's
very much like gbtc and they've been
largely ignored for the etf okay so
let's talk about etfs in general right
we know gold etf gld uh massive impact
on price uh how do you guys think about
just whatever the structure of the etf
ends up being what do we anticipate that
impact to be on the underlying uh kind
of bitcoin price if anything
i can jump in here real quick so i will
say one thing what gld did is different
from what this bitcoin etf is going to
do
if you were a retail investor you had no
real way of getting access to gold back
in the day like an etf opened up in a
completely new market right now there's
coinbase there's gemini there's ftf
everything everyone people have access
to bitcoin it's not basically
democratizing the entire space so i
would say like equating the the impact
of the etf on the gold market to the
uh bitcoin market is probably a little
far-fetched it's a little bit much um
again this is also futures but it's
definitely no matter what people say
people say it's like fake and paper
bitcoin but really it it is you're
buying bitcoin so any buying of this is
going to be um more demand on the actual
underlying bitcoin market in some way
and we can talk about margin
requirements for futures but the the
answer is that it's going to be positive
but it's not likely to be positive with
new demand into the etf but it's not
going to be
the same impact that we saw with gold
and also gold that was one of the
biggest best runs for gold that had it
launched right before uh not long before
the 2008 financial crash like there was
a whole bunch of other situations going
on there with with gold yeah and also
think there's a lot of optimism baked
into the uh run in bitcoin that we've
seen so while a bitcoin futures etf in
particular because that isn't even like
gld that's more like uso and we know
from history that things that track
futures in the etf market are largely
generally ignored by advisors which have
24 trillion in assets that's the real
giant pool of money that ets tend to tap
into the most
but there's traders and i think uso has
attracted traders this will attract
traders but i think the bigger issue
here and i think you know
we don't think there'll be uh this won't
be like some game changer i just heard i
saw a call that somebody from um
i won't say who it is but they thought
that this etf or the bitcoin futures
have taken 36 billion in flows in the
first year um that seems very uh overly
optimistic i would say more like four or
five now if it was etf tracking spot
bitcoin uh maybe we get to 30 billion um
you know given what we saw at gbtc and
up in canada but i i still think for the
futures one the big news here
is that a it gives traders something to
use
um it will be used by traders don't it
definitely will
uh but it's what it represents is this
slow start to the sec getting
comfortable with bitcoin and crypto you
could see ether you could see the
physical you could see people have
active funds that do crypto picking
inside an etf like an arc down the road
we go and all of a sudden now you're
talking about real assets but this
particular launch probably isn't going
to be like some big game changer asset
wise